citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
today we are going to do a first time
watching for the movie you're next
directed by Adam Winger the director of
Godzilla versus Kong I know this is a
home invasion Thriller that's about all
I know I've never seen a single clip or
a frame of movement from this film
before I've heard it's good it's been
recommended my way a bunch of times it's
Halloween season horror is actually my
favorite genre covered Sinister a couple
months ago you guys should go ahead and
check that out as well and also on my
list I have the movies X and Jennifer's
Body put in the comments which one you
want to see next and yes Gotta Give a
disclaimer here YouTube's been extra
extra sensitive as of late and uh this
has got a hard R so if some things have
to be you know blurred or whatever
censored please understand that when a
video gets age restricted that also
means that YouTube kind of hides it
buries it so even though we wouldn't be
monetized we would not even get views
for it so I just don't want that to
happen when I know this is going to take
several hours to put together but guys
please go ahead leave a like also
subscribe click the notification Bell to
get notified when we got a reaction up
here that piques your interest as always
and I am very grateful to all who have
joined our patreon page and become super
sexy rejects over there we have our
full-length Reaction watch alongs as
well as covering several shows where you
got reaction highlights and watch alongs
exclusively for several of those IPS and
uh the team at prepper thank you for
helping us set it down these highlights
I'm excited guys let's get into the
horror slasher mood
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh we are off to the races people
she doesn't now it looks satisfied
I don't know her but my Primal instincts
are telling me I am now emotionally
invested
oh oh come on be smarter than that and I
would immediately call the cops
all right
and now would be a good time to call the
cop
that's the title of the movie oh
nice
like a good blood Splat on the wall if
you guys are fans of Supernatural you
get a lot of that
I love that horror movie shot of the
Woods
and road on the woods
road on the woods that's a sentence
that's funny
uh that's not funny at all dude so your
parents are pretty loaded right I guess
my dad retired from kpg last year and he
got an insane sevens package wait kpg is
in the defense contractor
he was just in marketing though
I'm surprised this is your first time
having this conversation I want to meet
your family
my mom's on
a way to ruin the fun with your mental
health problems
oh
oh my God
sound is that it's gonna be that easily
thank you oh what a smart woman Aubry oh
yeah no you go outside I'm gonna check
the upstairs
you deserve to die
I'll take this with me okay
are you happy
no
all right you wait outside I'll be out
in a minute
why would your inclination not just you
should have already just want to take a
weapon
foreign
this is why I own RPGs
sorry guys this ain't enough True Crime
stuff to be like home invasion stuff is
something that you should take very
serious
oh my God what the hell
you scared the [ __ ] out of me yeah
you're a piece of [ __ ] son you know that
foreign
I love the voyeuristic approach of a lot
of these camera shots
hey you come here
oh we brought whiskey
well come on in that's a great offer
well I look forward to meeting the rest
of your family tomorrow
it's been a long time since we've all
been together so
it should be interesting oh it's going
to be a family Bloodbath
oh [ __ ] oh what a great shot it's in the
window and in the toaster oven oh that
is awesome hey everybody you ever see
kangaroos fight stop in a weird way do
some funny little Kelly
you almost hit my face
it's only a little chubby this is only a
little chubby I have a round face yeah
it doesn't mean that's right it doesn't
mean he's fat no it means you're
beautiful all the fat on him means he's
fat what a dick
so I guess she's the main character and
we're like experiencing this through her
poker cow for me can you could you go
over to the neighbor's house and see if
he has some yeah
okay
well I'll be right back
it's nice to feel like you have a
purpose
is there a doorbell
because that music is obnoxiously loud
that is messed up man but smart
you must be Terry yes nice to meet you
nice to meet you
meet you I'd like you didn't mean to see
a girlfriend
see nice to meet you
Z
wait
I know that actress don't I you're Aaron
yeah nice to meet you Scott dad maybe
horror films are always lit this way
it's like
kind of like a yellow dark tint to it
just want you all to know
how much it means to us that you're all
here so
thank you for coming
oh she's so cute
that poor mom's gonna get brutally
slaughtered I'm a filmmaker is that
right yeah
I don't think I know any filmmaker
makes sonic it's not a lot of us
interesting I've only made one
documentary was it the Cleveland
underground Film Festival 2008 did they
show the movies underground
[Laughter]
I just think do you do commercials
because those are my favorites no no he
doesn't do it really I just think that
is just the height of the art form these
days
foreign
[Laughter]
at this time of night through the window
a beautiful shot can be formed
foreign
[Music]
holy crap he got an arrow in his head
[Applause]
yeah get away from all the windows right
about now
no oh
if anyone deserved it
this is pretty intense man Jesus
[Music]
okay you're rich sons of [ __ ] gotta
own at least one gun right yeah they
must be using a Jammer what a cell phone
blocker they're illegal but you can get
them on the Internet for like 30 bucks
what are you calling me a low life for
man I'm just trying to help the
situation
hahaha
[Laughter]
I love that I keep fighting you're right
during this
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God
oh my God it's not gonna work
it's gonna be a two shot it's gonna be a
two for one right now
foreign
crossbows take a while to reload
Ed somebody should make a run for the
cars
no man what's wrong with you whoever's
the fastest runner who who is that I'm
the fastest man I've got this [ __ ]
Arrow what does your shoulder have to do
with your legs
you guys
pull the doors open at the last second
they're not going to be expected to be
coming out full speed
oh you should say her goodbyes
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
wow that was unexpected
[Applause]
oh that's horrifying
[Applause]
[Music]
oh Jesus that's
some scary [ __ ]
we need to make sure all the doors and
the windows are locked
what do you mean what she's got the
right [ __ ] idea man
what are you doing so
please cover up unlock all the windows
never seen you act like this before
I don't see your next situation yeah
dude go away with me I've never seen you
act like this before she's doing Jesus
Christ she's a goddamn Warrior
damn so there's a daughter like that
right in front of your eyes and the
documentary filmmaker underground film
cinema is never going to be the same
yeah
what's this girl's past
oh
[Laughter]
no
oh whoa
this goddamn Pig masks
[Applause]
that's cathartic
because
who is this actress she's freaking
awesome
[Music]
oh jeez
Geez Louise
what if that guy's still under the bed
no one should be left alone
why would you look without having a
weapon
Kelly
[Music]
foreign
you're so stupid
I get you're not thinking rationally but
[Music]
wow
ouch
solid punch damn
how violence is this gonna be
oh gosh
oh no
foreign
we need to get somebody out there in
here
I'm gonna go to the neighbors
as soon as I'm a safe distance away I'll
try to text and call if there's some big
plot twists coming
everything's gonna be fine out there
you just stay in here
Crispin you're dead
you're dead
this is what happens when you be able to
have unprofessionally in the workplace
the safety say at least one of them's
already inside
the person killed my wife stood in this
house
go find him
what's the best room for a solo banging
I don't know all the rooms have Windows
in them except for the basement no I
suppose that's a bad idea they can just
pull guests down the stairs and throw in
a match
who is she
she did know the Kirsten's dad's uh
background how should I carry a weapon
damn homie just burst right in
nice nice
bash is heading yeah
[Laughter]
she is so cool who is she
that's like a good force not forced head
trauma someone has to ask who she is
anyone know this guy
[Laughter]
oh she is the [ __ ] thanks for the help
by the way
where's he dead
I already want to know more about this
actress she is so cool
oh man they've been camping out where's
the circuit box
I don't know I think it's in the
basement like why don't you go look for
it there I'm gonna go upstairs and try
to find my dad
oh poor guy Alex
one of them was in the bedroom
they've been watching us for days
this wasn't a random attack okay okay
yeah
don't turn your back
[Music]
oh are they in on it
I've had I mean they're making it they
were they were shooting it was like they
were red on it
especially the girl
you had to do that right in front of me
are you saying something yeah you know
what
never mind
I had a feeling the girl was in on it I
was slightly suspicious of him but
looks like it'd be really hard to fight
through that mask
oh oh
here's Johnny
[Music]
hey
[Music]
whoa
yes oh yes get him in the face
oh come on guys
you guys okay what's going on
we heard noises so we stayed upstairs
we didn't find anyone
and your dad
ask about the dad
he just needed to lie down
how many of them do you think there are
to be at least two more of them
you just want to make sure that the nail
goes all the way through
see that
who is she she looks so familiar how did
you learn all this stuff
well I had
kind of a weird childhood I grew up on a
survivalist compound
I haven't even told Chris Ben that yet
you guys keep a lot from each other
move to the states with Mom when I was
15 but
I've learned a lot beforehand
that's crazy
now could he kill his own brother
three
Kelly's dead
man
her body's up there on the floor right
now
oh my God
you just die already
this is hard enough for me
that is some cruel [ __ ] man
oh you better not
I'm gonna go check on the dad upstairs
and when the boys come up make sure to
have some rope or something uh I can do
it I can go be careful
laughs
[Music]
stay on high
alert
[Music]
God damn
survivalist compound lady indeed
awesome
oh my god oh you can feel it I don't
know why you guys ever have once I
almost got glass really caught in my
foot and nailed to just oh
boy
foreign
Rich parents kids look for something to
be mad about
Home Alone
I'll be over soon
oh that's gross oh my God I really in
the mood right now Z
come on I'll make it quick
just so we're perfectly clear I
might kill my own brother
I'm just trying to think of reasons why
I should kill you
he's paying you
we did make it this far man
yikes
I just got a fist ready that's awesome
oh nice oh that is great great I love
her I love her so much
[Music]
you could have taken the stairs
[Music]
come on Judo chop him
foreign
nice
[Music]
she is so cool I want to take Krav Maga
classes right now
[Music]
oh yeah bring on the synth music people
[Music]
awesome I really hope Crispin doesn't
come running through that door
you know how to use that thing yeah I
know how to [ __ ] use it I pull the
trigger air shoots right two bolts Two
Shots you see here you make it count
[Music]
I am so fascinated by this performance
it's such a cool character such a such a
really cool character
I would expected nice flip on the genre
nice Motif I Like It Cool Style
I'm Batman
foreign
she is the definition of fight or flight
get in there
nice
murder her
[ __ ]
oh this is so cathartic
oh my God
that's what I'm talking about man holy
[ __ ]
that is
[Music]
awesome
I love it
oh
I love it
wow what an image oh man she took out
everyone that blender death was one of
the most brilliant things ever
no it's crisping in on this
ah what
you know I'm a pacifist I can't I can't
deal with the violent stuff
oh you cowered
it's it's [ __ ] freezing out here I'm
coming inside
Aaron
you're okay
where's Felix
I stuck a blender in his head and killed
him
[Laughter]
he would have killed me no
that was never supposed to happen you
were supposed to be the witness
a person with a clean record that could
attest that our family and neighbors had
been murdered by unknown lunatics things
got so out of control you deserve to die
so much I'm now the sole inheritor of my
family's estate
we're talking Millions babe
regardless of our current situation or
whatever we're going through
that's why he was like why are you
behaving this way
you could have 500 000 within a month
or
I go to jail
then you get nothing
oh
you better kill him
that's right move
easily The Right Move
[Music]
oh God what
stay alive
stay alive
just a tiny bit longer
we need medic and back up immediately at
five Edelweiss Drive
foreign
oh no the ax
that was awesome
said suspect on her Polaroid
there's cops failing to put it all
together
edited by Adam Winger too that's cool
all right guys I'm gonna have to talk
very efficient because uh time of
shooting this I have to move on to
editing something else right it's like
11 30 at night or something else I gotta
edits this is weird just uh kind of a
funky schedule this whole week that I've
been having but
um I really really enjoyed that there
was a a real cheeky kind of humor to it
I loved I loved its black humor man I
love the dark humor throughout and it
was just a really exciting film because
when it starts off it has this like
self-awareness that you think you're
sort of walking into uh traditional home
invasion movie where you know family is
going to mingle together and then bam
there's going to be some serial killers
to show up something a little bit more
straightforward and direct kind of like
the strangers movies you know the
strangers I I'm I haven't I don't recall
pray at night too well I don't know I'm
sure if you've seen that movie but uh
like the strangers it's a typical home
invasion movie serial killer slasher and
such but there was a lot of great
whodunit flares to it and there was uh
it was almost like an Agatha Christie
Vibe about it where you have the family
mingling together and instead of just
the body count of the family members it
starts to become a question of like
who's involved who's really behind all
this why is this all going down is it
you know because at first it's sort of
leading you into this belief that these
are psychopaths attacking them and that
perhaps there's some type of ritual
behind it you know especially with the
fact that they're riding on the walls
like you're next that it does seem like
there's some type of ritual occurring
you're out in the woods and they're
masked up and is there like symbolism
behind the mask
but then you start to you know
eventually latch on them so one of these
people might be in on it so I like that
there was a bit of this
it's like a physical comedy quality to
it and a bit of a screwball comedy Vibe
uh with a bit of an Agatha Christie
Flair as well with a home invasion Vibe
and also an action movie and a horror
movie all in one I thought that was
great like the way they they fleshed all
those elements together I thought had a
great natural build to it because
in the beginning it does feel like some
of the dialogue does feel like a little
bit cheesy but then it just works so
well and you know it's there are parts
that feel like a bit of a because I
think a lot of it just comes down to if
you strike the right tone you can get
away with certain kinds of expositional
dialogue like when Aaron is hiding who
is this woman by the way
hold up
Charney Vinson
God I know I'm in a rush right now but I
I gotta know who this person is my God
she was
phenomenal
I I loved her she was so incredible I
don't think I've seen her at this I
think this is the only thing I've ever
seen her in
she is so good
I love the the handling of her character
we gotta talk about that because yeah
like they're planting the seeds in there
of dysfunctional family and you kind of
think maybe it's gonna go one specific
way because in the beginning of the film
I was sort of going all right whose
perspective are we latching on to it
eventually you know I was like okay I
think this is Aaron's perspective that
we are ultimately capturing this movie
from because you're like is it crispin's
perspective that we're seeing this film
through you know he's the son having to
return to his families obviously
ambivalent towards them or watching as
he's driving to them and bringing his
girlfriend and perhaps he's the one
who's gonna have to go on a character
Arc and there's like a completely
different movie that this could have
been where
through the course of these events you
watch as these brothers like Drake and
Crispin overcome their odds and then
somehow through these actions of
standing up in the violence and whatever
that they become a family unit again or
or some something like that there's
there's like that tale they could have
told but I really love the direction of
this because of that who'd done a kind
of flare it and then having this sort of
action element to it
it provides something very unique and
different and very unexpected it's a
nice flip on the genre like the version
I pitched you just now is the very
predictable version that it could have
gone down which could have been a great
character-driven Nuance piece sure maybe
there's a way that you could have done
that as well then it could have hit the
right players still got the cool
violence but this version especially
with the Aaron character because like at
the very beginning of the film I don't
remember the specific lines but they're
first seen together Crispin and Aaron
she knows it's a good uh uh it's a good
way of alluding to the fact that she
knows a little bit more about things
than you would expect when it comes to
the background of
killers and stuff and survivalists so
you're you do slowly start to pick up
and there are these little clues that
Kristen might be in on it because like I
thought that line of dialogue was a
little corny and it's like I've never
seen you behave like this when she's
getting all assertive after really
getting lost in the blood and that is
the moment for her character a fight or
flight like what do I do and it's time
to buckle down and you get this sense
that she had
um an oppressive childhood something
that like I think the performance is
great and the writing is awesome too
because you get this sense that she had
a a real oppressive childhood and rather
traumatic you know being taken away at
15 and being brought up to have these
sort of sets of beliefs and that you
would the world is going to end and it's
going to be like an apocalyptic
landscape you're gonna have to learn to
kill you're gonna have to learn to
survive in these really dark times and
just having the sort of beliefs and then
you can imagine that her character went
down this path of having just a
completely different life and trying to
get away from all that and then bam and
this incident happens and all those
things that were sort of pushed away
that you wouldn't even tell the the man
who she loves about her true past you
wouldn't even let him in on that piece
of information
eventually you know some more I'm
talking about and I'm going back to the
beginning of the moon like man there
were a lot of great Clues laid
throughout even with Crispin and the way
how he reacts to the family of when
she's like a lot of people would love to
have parents like yours and you could
see how uh resistant he is towards just
receiving that and taking that anyway
um when it when it came to uh her
character you're watching as everything
about her is just becoming the full
survivalist everything she was sort of
raised to be in her early ages of life
that they talk about you watch as she
sort of morphs into this by the very end
you know it's step by step being
cautious being cautious and then
eventually just full on violence
breaking through and I love the
trajectory of her character and I
thought the performance was awesome and
the way the movie starts to take some
turns with you know slowly showing The
Killers having the reveals there and
then before he know it when they put
their masks on they're not even scary
and you just get you get to the point
where you just want to watch her mess
all these guys up I thought was
excellent and it was fun it was pulpy it
was inventive with some of its kills it
was disturbing but it never got like too
mean-spirited to the point where uh you
know like sometimes in certain movies
I like I like good campy violence and I
like Pulp and all that I I like Gore I I
do enjoy it and there are times though
contextually where I go this is just too
mean for my spirit like in Halloween
kills there's this early on in the films
if you haven't seen a slight spoiler
where Michael Myers kills this old
couple
and then uh while the old woman's dying
she watches as Michael is like
experimenting with which knife to use by
stabbing it into the body of the Dead
old guy and I'm like why'd she have to
be alive to witness this this is so mean
like I watched that film every time I
see that movie I'm like this is just
mean that's mean I don't like it like
there's mean stuff here like brothers
killing brothers and stuff they're just
killing their family members it's mean
but there's a certain tone that the film
strikes where it doesn't cross into two
mean-spirited there's a there's a sense
of fun even amongst the more like
disturbing family qualities to it
there's a there's a morbid Macabre type
of sensibility that I really enjoy and
yeah I remember Christmas I thought he I
the crisp and twist because like with
the brother Felix and then the Z the
woman I
it wasn't surprising I I had a thought
going off in the way they were Framing
and I feel like Adam Winger wanted to
kind of clue you in that he was part of
it Crispin for some reason I I just
thought he might just show up at the end
uh part of me was worried that they were
gonna pull some [ __ ] where he just
walks through the door and the ax hits
him like I was actually really concerned
that might happen
but they didn't do that and they instead
gave us a Twist that lined up it made
sense it makes sense to everything else
and while there's a lot of like
Exposition dumps I thought they used it
in the in the right right framing like
it's it's certain Exposition and be
forgivable again tone and and again you
know like when Felix is freaking out
explaining all the things that are
giving all the information to to uh
Aaron while she's hiding behind the
corners it works works in the scene and
even with um
you know it's like if Chrisman picks
Chrisman calls Felix and she picks up
his phone and he just starts dumping
information like that's just a little
silly but when she when he is like
revealing the whole plan
he's also pleading he knows that he
could die so he's also trying to bargain
with her so that way he can you know
keep his life because he is ultimately a
coward and I I like the way they they
formed that relationship at the very
beginning because they they don't reveal
like oh my God is actually this ultimate
Mastermind killer guy he's not as
cowardly as he as he puts up
you you get the sense of the with the
history of their relationship that oh
he's the exact opposite of the kind of
of her dad essentially the way how Aaron
grew up and she talks about her father
you get the sense that you know as she
wanted
to have a different roadmap for her life
not the one she grew up in that she was
drawn to someone like Chrisman who is
the complete opposite of that
and they maintain that complete
oppositeness while those are giving us
this villainous turn about him and I
think the way the a lot of the way the
family Dynamics I thought was fleshed
out really well like all that dinner
table stuff seemed part of it seemed
improvised
um it would have just added the sense of
realism like I like how during the most
violent hectic chaotic moments of just
pure intensity they would sometimes keep
that family bickering still alive it was
great I had
so much fun with this the music choices
were great there's a lot of great
framing devices in here that do feel
it feels like it's doing its own thing
kind of feels like the example when you
do the guest as well because
um uh there are times I was thinking of
the guests did he do the guest
I'm looking it up he did do the guest
okay yeah that makes sense that makes a
lot of sense that way because there were
definitely times I was thinking about
the guest and I really liked that movie
oh that would have been a good one to
react to on this channel why did I have
to watch it on my own time uh I really
like the guest a lot so yeah again
that's another movie with a revealing of
the character throughout I don't want to
ruin that for anyone if you haven't seen
it watch the guest that's a great movie
um but yeah I think keeping it at Close
Quarters a contained film and the the
way the reveals went down I thought I
had a lot of colorful personalities to a
lot of the characters
and
it was just it was fun that was just a
really fun horror movie it was fun it
was the time suspenseless and had some
really good jump scares
I'm trying to think of something I
didn't like and just because I feel like
I gotta contribute something to the like
a criticism uh other than some points of
expositional dialogue that didn't quite
click with me but I was so invested in
the main character and I think the way
how you discover who she is through her
actions is is great
and
yeah no it was
this is cool it's a cool movie man it's
cool I like how it took its turn into
sort of a b pulpy film from a from a
suspenseful home invasion movie to a
like a pulpy cathartic violent action
film that was awesome
kind of like the cast and
um guys what do you think about this
movie you're next I thought this was
awesome this was a really awesome film
and uh I'd like to watch it again and
sort of just study it because I thought
there was some wonderful composition to
the shots because so much of it is
handheld yet it also to really add up
that intensity beef up that intensity
yet at the same time there were some
just really great composition with its
shots and a lot of messing with
perspective I thought was awesome that
it constantly had this voyeuristic touch
especially in the first half um a lot
and watching how the table's turnover
time is great
ah drake drake drake drake drake drake
there's some stupid character choices of
course but you know as again when you
get into this like fearful state I'm
like I don't know what it'd be like to
be in a situation so would I be the
idiot who runs out the door sure why not
I mean
I'd like to think I'd be logical and
composed and be [ __ ] Aaron in this
situation but I'm like maybe not I'd
probably freak out too at some point and
make the wrong call and split up or
something like that when I shouldn't be
splitting up
but for the most part now this is good
it was great it was a great time I could
see why people Rave about this movie
Ladies and Gentlemen leave your thoughts
down below leave a like subscribe click
that Bell
and last but not least let's end this
with a
kale Linden Mikhail if I was stuck in a
home invasion situation I feel like
you'd be the right guy to know because
there's something about you that just
reads a pure intellect especially with
the kind of films you're really into I
feel like you'd really understand what
kind of weapons we need how to set up
Contraptions all kinds of gimmicks and
gadgetry probably go on MacGyver on
everyone's asses and that's the kind of
guy you need in a home invasion
situation some kale I hope that the time
I take a trip to Sweden that eventually
when I'm in your home chilling getting
to know the family
that some people try to break in and
maybe annihilate us and then that's when
I get to see the true side of Mikhail
come out
the monster within and he tries to
resolve this guilt by staying a loyal
super sexy reject or patreon page
Thinking by giving
that will absolve him of the monster
within him but it won't if anything I'm
just going to use all the earnings from
patreon to make sure to hire these
burglars to break in just so I can
Unleash the Beast Within you and force
all that repressed trauma to come out of
you because that's the way I roll
Mikhail and I love my people at our
patreon just that much that I want to
see their true colors go back
[Music]